good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day so far we
are because we're wearing our new merch
summer collection spring summer joggers
spring summer we're wearing new merch we
are both wearing the crew necks you guys
know we love a crew neck in the summer
but we all there's other stuff there's
other stuff so these are the two crew
necks this is our like morning toast
weekday Club collection if you're
watching on YouTube Claudia and Iran the
crew next Claudia is wearing pink I'm
wearing green there's also t-shirts
there's shorts there are baby onesies
there are tote bags something we've
never done before I'm so excited about
this collection and we were wearing them
yesterday and now I'm wearing it again
today and it's just like the cutest look
the cutest look we'd like a full-blown
photo shoot in the street yesterday
shout out to the toaster in the wild who
saw us taking pictures of each other and
offered to take a photo oh she starts
taking pictures of each other they told
us she loves the show we asked her to
take a picture of us she delivered she
delivered for our photo shoot and that's
the kind of like boots on the ground
work we love to see here at the morning
us yeah so that launches Friday Friday
10 a.m Pacific Time Pacific time so 1
p.m Eastern ooh spooky spooky so
obviously don't get confused it's not
chanelofficial.com it is
shopmorningtoast.com I know it's so
confusing because people are always like
Claudia help I'm going to Neiman
marcus.com and I can't find the merch
and it happens all the time because like
we're so high-end but it's just
exclusive to shopmorningtoast.com this
happens to be like an exclusive capsule
collection so
um maybe in the future we'll be at
chanel.com but for now it's still
shopmorningtoast.com yeah it's a really
really cute collection I will be wearing
my look today you do look really cute
we'll be wearing all the new items
throughout the week photos on our
Instagram if you're looking for
um inspo I'm wearing XL as usual I'm
wearing XL I probably should be wearing
a large in this for wearing it oversized
but um
I had a medium instead and I just didn't
want it to be so snug 100 so snug so
snug on me these days but sizing is as
always these are the usual crew necks
nothing nefarious not any thicker not
any thinner they're what you've come to
know and love from TMT mm-hmm
so again that's Friday 10 a.m Pacific 1
pm Eastern
um it's Tuesday which means there's no
TV recap there's no unburdened ourselves
and there's no dear toaster so we just
have the the whole afternoon just to
like talk about ourselves which
is the best yeah we had a crazy night oh
my God I'm thinking like why am I so
like bloated and tired because we were
literally out till midnight on a Monday
yeah we did something really special
last night Claudia and Margo plan
something really sweet for me as like a
farewell Endeavor and it was a surprise
Claudia blindfolded me it was a whole
thing she blogged everything for the
patreon and I'm so excited to watch it
to see like whatever what all happened
before I was privy to what we were doing
yeah it was um a gorgeous night it was I
don't want to like
spilled too much you know we did run
into some fellow famous people so I
really don't wanna I don't wanna spoil
it because
it's on the patreon so after this I have
all the content already I will be
editing the Vlog on my way to Boston
which is where I'm going today for the
Spritz meet and greet at six o'clock all
the information is on the Spritz
Instagram account so if you're a Boston
girly you want to drink you want to
party you want to take pics 6 to 8 p.m
tonight so I'll be editing the Vlog in
route to Boston I've decided to drive
because I just don't feel comfortable
for my mental health to fly anymore oh
yeah no if you have the option between
flying and driving right now and drive
yeah like I would Ben was like I've been
in bed last night was like I really wish
we were flying I'm like why would you
put yourself through that like you can
be guaranteed however many hours it is
driving like three and a half four three
and a half or you could be
two hours could be 12 hours yeah no it's
like those 40 minute like Regional
flights are the ones that always are
getting like shafted
yeah so I feel good about my decision so
the Vlog will be up today it was really
a great night I ate so much like that
cake
um
I'll be dreaming about it I ate a lot
but I kind of wish I ate more you know
the feeling not that there was anything
more for me to eat because we really
licked every plate clean but I almost
wish like we ordered more like I wish it
was stuffed and I wish I had leftovers
in the fridge you did take home
leftovers oh yeah but not of the the
stuff you wanted the regular the good
stuff was gone the good stuff was
exactly yeah
um it was delicious like really premium
and like a Bittersweet evening it was
but mostly sweet every it was really
nice to have the gang back together we
haven't all had like a gno yeah in a few
months and then this was a weeknight gno
it was kind of crazy to be out on a
Monday at midnight we were kind of like
the morning toast weekday club like
crazy kids out on the town we're just
doing everything on the weekdays so that
you can take off on the weekend it's so
true I'm like a big proponent of doing
the most on the weekdays
um and nothing on the weekends yeah me
as well so you got your liquid death
this is not sponsored by the way no it's
not it's just such a great product and I
look so badass don't I are you guys
looking at me like oh my God that girl
is trouble are you gonna pump and dump
because you're drinking beer really
funny like Four Loko do you think Harry
would like for Loco I think he would
like liquid death for sure I've actually
been drinking liquid deck for the last
few weeks and he likes it good good also
we went to a concert and all of the
water there was Liquid death which makes
a lot of sense because it's cans instead
of plastic and again like oh you're not
drinking at a concert but you look sick
your cans look sick your cans look sick
you look like piece of wood
um recipe shells of sunset that has lost
the community will or at least I will
never get over it's disgusting yeah and
then you think of all the other shows
that are still on TV you know
are you gonna be watching Love Island
USA it's making its return I was gonna
ask you that because I saw you had your
love Island water bottle and I saw that
it's on peacock like starting today
Ariel Vandenberg is no longer the host
because it moved from CBS to Peacock now
it's Sarah Hyland
um I don't think I don't know I don't
think I'm gonna watch because like I
really enjoyed it last year it was like
so fun and exciting but
everyone is pretty much under the like
same understanding that UK is so much
better and it's happening right now and
apparently it's crazy I don't know
what's going on but like if I'm gonna
spend all my time watching a show I'm
gonna watch the loser version you know
yeah plus when it's on peacock and
everyone watches at different times like
you're not really a part of something
like you were when it was live and
that's what you really enjoyed about it
and I don't understand my love Island us
I can't get their [ __ ] together and be
nearly as good as love Island UK I don't
know why either maybe it's the accents
or something but like it's just not
working in this format yeah I don't
think it's going to do any better on
peace yeah I would have a better chance
if it was live because then okay I'll
watch this episode and then maybe in a
few days I'll watch again but you have
to be really dedicated to like choose it
out of all the streamers and all the
world to choose that episode out of all
the streamers in all the world you
decided to walk into mine and peacock is
just not
my favorite honestly
really
performance on if I pay for it I'll
watch it yeah but I'm like always
canceling my peacock like I only
resubscribe when I need to watch
something you know oh I keep all my
streamers active because I have YouTube
TV so I get my costs back I mean like I
don't pay for cable I pay for YouTube TV
which is much cheaper which gives me
more budget for all the streaming
services I like never get over the fact
that you're like a cord cutting
Millennial no cable because it's so not
you that's me I'm just extremely cool
young hip on Trend it's so not you to be
like like a Maverick you know I'm a
Maverick like you're rebelling against
cable you I'm so Maverick and literally
throw Maverick as well yeah it's
important for everyone to know like it
really wasn't your call exact one and
YouTube TV so you just went along with
it and it's a very much exact thing to
do 100 but I just no I'm someone who
loves things about you I'm someone who
would have cable and have every channel
because I just couldn't decide you
probably also get YouTube TV and you
just never know when you're gonna need
that Channel stars I love having cable I
can't lie but I have every streaming
service and I pay for all of them and I
don't cancel them like Hallmark movies
now Lifetime movie club like uh Acorn
and even though I don't watch stuff on
them all the time and Jack is always
like when can we cancel I'm like you
just never know yeah so because I pay
for cable I monitor my streaming
services a little bit more like I catch
up on RuPaul's Drag Race on Paramount
plus cancel it and then when I have new
episodes I redo it wow yeah no I'm like
really cheap and annoying that's because
I pay a lot for cable because I also
have home internet cable and home phone
all wrapped up into a bundle and I
really need to cancel my home phone like
I don't even have it plugged in
but what about you know in case of like
a nuclear I can't imagine your home
phone bill is what's no it's like 12 a
month yeah no it's not so I think you
should leave that I know and you like
talking about that you have a home phone
I do and also it increases engagement on
my social media because anytime my home
phone is in the background of any of my
content you have a M phone tell me
that's not a landline Claudia shut up oh
my God like sorry I'm safe like I'm
always thinking like there's an
apocalypse or like New York just dropped
this cringy ass PSA like what to do in
case of nuclear warfare like as if
that's you know a potential like
possibility
um
and you know your cell phone won't work
in case of a nuclear warfare so call me
on my landline [ __ ] okay
if you paid me six million dollars right
in that now Claudia what is the phone
number of your landline I couldn't tell
you yeah but we'll call you there yeah
we'll look it up call me during nuclear
warfare we'll get out the Yellow Pages I
put my home phone number in our like
family chat when I first got it so maybe
you saved it
[Music]
but like I can remember phone numbers
from and maybe this is just like a
byproduct if you were a kid of course
like my best friends I can literally
remember our dead father's cell phone
number like but I don't know you know
your parents phone number like yeah but
I haven't like had the need to call my
dad no but it's 2009. but still like you
remember your friends phone numbers from
growing up do you know Zach's phone
number by heart I do after so many years
of like having to put it on medical
forms and this and that a few years ago
I realized that I had it memorized yeah
I get it it's a good thing do you know
your social security number yep when I
was um getting my passport renewed in
like the seventh grade Olivia like
escorted me to the post office and we
were waiting in line and she was like
this is like Olivia she's so smart you
know she was like you really should know
your social security number by heart I'm
like okay so she made up a song while we
were waiting in line in the post office
and every time I read it I'm like Ma
it's like each number and honestly was
like one of the greatest gifts she ever
gave me because I always remember it
yeah that's really nice Olivia also
taught me how to ride a bike did she
I don't remember that I do core memory
in the driveway that would be a
corporate okay what are one of your core
memories
last night oh God no from childhood oh I
have so many wonderful memories when you
peed on my head in the bathtub
that was a great day good times good
times no like a positive one oh okay
um just put me on the spot or like a
random memory that you happen to
remember you know
yeah oh I have a lot of those like my
first memories like I just remember
being in pre-k you do yeah I feel like I
shared this recently maybe not on the
show maybe in my private life I was in
pre-k and I remember it was uh spring
and was one of those spring days where
it was hot but I was still dressed for
winter I was wearing a dress and I was
like I'm very hot I was like ah this is
too hot for spring that's my core memory
and that's actually my earliest memory
of my life being so hot in the Pre-K
that is so oh speaking of being hot I'm
I'm like done
two nights ago we went to the
OneRepublic Concert and it was so hot
and I was sweating like I think that's
the way people sweat after like a
full-blown like 90-minute Soul cycle
class and then last night we had to wait
like seven minutes for our table and we
stood outside the restaurant and I was
literally like not okay dripping melting
having to go inside I think there's
something going on with me and I just
want to say like I'm done I'm ready for
the winter weather like I want to make a
chili I want to cultivate A vibe and I'm
[ __ ] done no it's just a heat wave no
but like everyone is experienced
everyone was hot but nobody was having
like the problems I was having why don't
you get like the botox of the armpits
and all that jazz I wasn't even sweating
in my armpits that jazz here's where I'm
sweating like forehead neck upper lip
behind my neck crevices like can I get
BOTOX in my crevices you could get
anti-swedding pills you can
I feel like I sweat more than the
average person like yes I think it's
partially contributed to the fact like
that I actually don't think that you
sweat some people have a sweating
problem yeah I don't think that you do I
think you sweat when it's hot
how do we stop that like I'm really not
a sweating pill anti-swept pill I didn't
realize that that existed description
yeah looking into it call your doctor
because I'm just like always the hottest
person in every room and everyone's like
yeah you are smoking
but they're dealing with it yeah well I
think it's also because like we hang out
a lot and I don't no no I don't run cold
but like I fight the sweat with
everything oh I don't know I'm so done
with sweating like I'm so done with
literally everything I wear having to
like be dry cleaned like I'm [ __ ]
done at One Republic that was a sweat
Fest yeah but I was literally sweating
three times as much as you
perhaps you could have literally filled
a water bottle with a sweat on my neck
no I was so sweaty my clothes have to be
dry cleaned it's just like it's an
exactly I just don't want to like go out
anymore like leave my house it's unsafe
and because you were leaving your house
a lot I have to stop
it's not good for me no and there's also
a heat wave so just take the week off
there is a heat wave everywhere first of
all kind of set on a warning yesterday
like oh yeah we're about to [ __ ] up
warning I was on a zoom with some people
who are in New York and one person's
lights were flickering
and then the rest of the country it's
like even worse triple degrees like many
places I don't want to jinx it but like
do you remember like in like maybe the
last 20 years there were like two major
blackouts the entire island of Manhattan
went dark
that's like kind of a Vibe you know
except for the air conditioning and like
the crime and yeah it's the purge yeah
but like I don't know we were all you
know United back then I don't think so
no I don't think so either but um it
just made me think we haven't had a
blackout in a while like we're almost
due for one you know or maybe they've
learned I would hope if there's a
blackout the squatter in my house like
will definitely bust out from inside the
mirror and just like start taking it
because he's gonna be sweating and he's
gonna yeah you can't hide it anymore no
then I'm gonna become the squatter
because he's gonna take over my house
and I'm gonna have to squat behind the
bathroom mirror yeah you don't have a
squatter in your house why do you think
that I just know I do because of airdrop
and because I dropped the towel on your
floor I can feel like his presence or
her but it's definitely I can feel his
presence I can't explain it and I heard
someone cough
okay
good luck to you tell me if you need
anything I definitely have a squatter I
gotta install cameras just so I can go
viral once it comes out you know oh
those videos go crazy videos that could
be me like think of the engagement I
don't really think you can have someone
like living in your walls in New York
City I think you can
we don't have enough space here you know
why wouldn't you go live in a Suburban
wall
it's because it's easier to get found
out in a Suburban home but like you can
go between Apartments like you think
that there's not a lot of space but
you're building like the walls the vents
the duck the walls are paper thin now I
live in a pre-war building so they're
actually quite large actually a mansion
for a squatter okay keep me posted I
will I will I'm always looking behind my
bathroom mirror like I know you're in
there that's where they live like you
know if you have yeah
you know I went to I'm like a squatter
Rabbit Hole like a year ago and now I'm
fully convinced I just always feel like
a presence you know yeah and then one
time in the middle of the night like I
did you guys will fall in love oh that'd
be cute maybe he watches you in the
bathroom mirror like and he's like
you're so beautiful but he sees you
being so hard on yourself oh my God yeah
wait okay so this is obviously a
Hallmark movie what are we calling it
squatting into love okay or
squatters right into her heart something
like that yeah because you know
squatters rights are a thing yeah which
are insane by the way swatters right
it's like no you literally don't own
this house
um okay so that's enough about me what's
up with you not much you business as
usual
cool you know I saw you 20 seconds no I
know it's like we are caught we have to
stop hanging out after work because
after hours after hours because like
then I really have nothing to catch up
with you on the podcast with you know
yeah well not to be so morbid but like
no shut up like shut the [ __ ] up
obviously I know just shut up okay so I
think without further Ado
where are you
Mommy's little angel
where is Brew I'm his favorite auntie
where is Brew he's so soft and sweet
where is
[Music]
he's at home with Papa okay
Bryson mommy loves you thrice and he
loves you bye
brass and shots Madison resins
Dora the Explorer perfect little Dora
crunchy Angel Dora Gorgeous Hair Dora
precious man Dora cutest nose Dora love
of my life Dora something sweet Dora I'm
crying okay I feel like I feel good we
need to record those Tunes will you book
a studio session I'll come up for it
I'll call my producer spend the day and
we'll just bang it out I'll call my
producer and call Ryan Tedder because we
need his sick beat you know what I was
actually thinking
um about approaching him you know I'll
put together a deck like a pitch deck
and I know he only works with like
Beyonce and Taylor Swift and Adele but I
feel like why not Bryce insurance he
doesn't even know like the level of
iconicism that would erupt if we all got
the studio together like and yeah he's
like all right girl so like tell me what
you want to do and we would be like Ryan
Mr Tedder
where is Brew he must need his auntie
Ryan what about this tell me tell me
what you're feeling
rest and shots
how about this check this out
let me be and I'll be like that sounds
familiar no it's completely original
Ryan yeah he wrote the original 100 it's
just a remix yeah
now without further Ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
Spritz Society for us there's no summer
without Spritz Society from pre-gaming
to poolside there's something about
sipping Spritz that instantly elevates
your Vibe and now with the launch of
their newest flavor Peach we can't see
ourselves reaching for anything else for
the rest of the season so as you guys
know we sit next to Kansas bird Society
every day this is peach the new flavor
we've got grapefruit we've got lemon
we've got blood orange we've got
pineapple and now the new peach flavored
sparkling cocktails they are wine based
real wrong real wine real flavors real
ingredients this is one of our passion
projects we love Spritz we've been
chugging them all summer if you haven't
tried it Now's the Time we're available
at select stores but in certain States
but if you want to get it head over to
spritzociety.com because if you don't
already know Sports Society is a premium
sparkling cocktail made from real
California white wine and natural fruit
flavors the white wine base means it's
perfect for our gluten-free gurlies and
if you can't decide on just one flavor
try the original four flavors with the
variety eight pack that we just launched
so now you can try all the flavors in
one pack it's eight cans two of each
flavors you can also use code toast
today and get 10 off of grapefruit blood
orange pineapple lemon and Peach cheers
y'all spritzociety.com code toast check
it out Peach you guys that's my new
favorite flavor it's really good and I
would venture to say that these cans
have big Flav but yeah look how big love
literally should we steal that yeah yeah
but we'll spell it differently yes so
that you guys know that it's fob and so
Snapple doesn't sue us right
our first story in Chelsea Handler and
Joe Coy break up ahead of their first
anniversary Chelsea Handler is back on
The Dating Market the former Chelsea
Lately host revealed Monday night the
cheap hearted ways with her boyfriend
Joe Coy ahead of their one year
anniversary
she said in anticipation of celebrating
our first year together Joe and I
recorded this video early but as many of
you have noticed it is with a heavy
heart to announce that we have decided
together that it's best for us to take a
break from our relationship right now
this man blew my heart open with love
and because of him my life experience
has changed forever to be loved and
endured by Joe Coy has been one of the
greatest Gifts of my life she said that
he renewed her faith in men adding that
she has never been more optimistic for
the future
I was so surprised by this so why did
they break up then I don't know she has
all these amazing things to say
especially because they
um were so like gushy on social media
and then it just felt like
boom break up like it's I'm really
surprised when like they recorded a
video for their one year anniversary and
then broke up before they could even
celebrate their one year anniversary
like what happened in this nap it must
have been like something really quick
and major and I was just but nothing
nefarious because she wouldn't be
speaking about him like this right and I
definitely thought this was like OTP for
Chelsea Handler you know like I didn't
even have to think about whether or not
they would break up because
like I just thought for sure that this
was it
I was really surprised and people are
taking this really hard because like
yeah I think a lot of people identified
with Chelsea's like Journey on love like
being really kind of like pessimistic
about it
um and then like having her you know
mind blown with the love from Joe coy so
I was just really surprised and like
kind of sad I thought this was a good
match yeah I just don't understand how
she could say all these wonderful things
about him in their relationship and then
not be together
their anniversary was coming up
no it's definitely weird
I'm curious yeah maybe we should do a
podcast on it because she's a podcaster
now yeah perfect platform
perfect platform it's really the perfect
platform for anything to explore your
feelings comedy original music
explore your feelings it's really people
love to explore their feelings they
really do because you can take your time
no commercial break well there are but
like it's not no time constraints it's
not like Jimmy Kimmel like tell your
worst story and we'll laugh at it oh you
know what
what's late night TV is becoming more
and more Dreadful every day
yeah and it's just like what does the
future hold for late night TV because I
feel like at one point like back in the
day it was like the Pinnacle of comedy
of entertainment of celebrity and now
it's just like clowns doing clown [ __ ]
but don't you ever feel like in the
mainstream it's like nobody's watching
this stuff like nobody except for you
know some airports and stuff like keep
these channels how many people watch the
Clips online of their favorite
celebrities nobody really and for the
amount of distribution that they have
even if they have a hundred thousand
viewers like that's nothing because it's
just nothing it just says
nobody's watching it but like the big
wigs like don't care and they just like
keep propping up this trash no and I
think that um where like a huge problem
in late night is the people who do tune
in regularly skew much older and with
the guests that they bring on like
they're always trying to you know Target
gen Z so like Emma Chamberlain comes on
and even like these big A-list celebs
they play these dumb [ __ ] games and
it's like the older people who are
watching this show don't want to watch
this so it's like who is this for I
don't know and I do think that like it
feels like there is no they don't have
to hit ratings they don't have to get
viewers like there's no like
accountability it's like we're just
gonna keep these shows on because that's
what we decide we want to have yeah and
I think that they definitely get like
huge spikes in viewership depending on
the guests like a it was a really big
deal like I think maybe one or two weeks
ago Emma Chamberlain was on for the
first time and like I'm sure so many
people like young people tuned in and
like watched all the clips on on social
media
um but like to have a show that's
predicated like the viewership is
predicated on who your guest is that's
just very new you know if a successful
show means a lot of people are watching
your Clips on social media then you're
just a website you're a web show iCarly
yeah
and I do feel like a lot of the times I
haven't physically like sat down at my
TV and watched Jimmy Fallon or any of
those shows in years or sometimes when
I'm on tour and like there's like basic
cable like that's the only thing I'll
watch
um but I see so many Clips on social
media so it's like they're really
turning into web shows and if they were
smart they would pivot like into like
the greatest web show of all time yeah
yeah I just I don't know how low they
have to go before it's like oh this
isn't working but like how many people
are tuning into like Late Night with
Jimmy Fallon I think a couple hundred
thousand no based on um just people who
lost their amount and stuff tonight's
show there's no way it has to be
Millions to like a prime time on NBC I I
would be shocked
late night ratings here as of June 2021.
but okay but it's 2022 but oh it's 2022
oh my God I forgot
um but I can't imagine that much has
changed so at 11 30 PM it's competitive
between Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon and
Colbert okay
um viewers aged 18 to 49 oh my God
you're right Jackie how much is it and
that's the demo that advertisers care
about so so the Late Show which one's
that Jimmy Kimmel
no no let's go there he's in the lead by
the way which is shocking because I find
him like yeah we don't even like so we
just say the Jimmy I find him like the
least like relatable or like welcoming
and that's like the point of late night
is at the top with 430 000 viewers The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
345. Jimmy Kim alive my Instagram
stories get more views than that Jimmy
Kimmel Live with 300 I'm shocked I told
you I was like it has to be Millions no
so that's why the question what would
like Kim Kardashian go on no no besides
that because I'm sure it's like fun and
that you were all thread carpet and like
they just traditional celebrities like
traditional celebrity things right but
like the people in charge like how bad
do these shows have to do before they're
like we're pulling the plug it just
feels like they don't have to hit
ratings like they're just gonna sit
there and do this show and nobody's
gonna watch like for forever when they
do the demographic of adults between 25
and 54 so like a bigger it's still under
a million but it's a little higher like
600 500 000 4000. so it's just because
it's under a million
under a million for prime time
is tragic
you know they're very confusing with
these numbers no because across total
viewers I forgot about Seth Meyer is it
relevant across total viewers using
Myers late night averaged a million
views over the season James Corden
averaging 971 000 that's across all
demographics right and that's also like
you can pump up those numbers a little
bit you know because that includes when
Kim Kardashians and that includes when
people DVR it like yeah but never watch
it and that's still such a low number
that is I'm shocked I know Cable's on
the decline but like
that's crazy to me that's like
numbers like that's cool that's
successful podcast numbers yeah
Shook and and a lot of successful
podcasts have no distribution and they
don't get guests like that no
which is like people talking I thought
you were like definitely underestimating
like yeah it's gone down but it's still
three million
that just makes you wonder like why you
know a movie studio will be would be
hell-bent on their
you know starve their movie doing The
Tonight Show like they'd be better off
literally doing podcast rounds do you
feel like a lot of the people in Talent
Industries are coming around to that you
see like Tom Brady's on podcast yeah
Kardashians are like people are
realizing that but I'm curious about the
people upstairs like who have to answer
to advertisers right and advertisers why
are they advertising I'm sure they have
to pay like a premium to be on cable
when they could reach that many active
listening engaged people who selectively
turned on a podcast instead of losing
their remote you know what's a good
um comparison hot ones because that's
like an interview sit down talk show web
show they have 11.5 million subscribers
and their most recent episode which I
believe was with Chloe oh no there's now
one with Daniel kaluya from five days
ago that's already up to 1.5 million
yeah Gabriel Iglesias two million Tessa
Thompson 1.7 million three million Chloe
three million like that's crazy
wow you gotta invest in digital
yeah you do I mean and that's what
they're doing yeah and then I guess that
makes sense as to like why whenever TV
execs like wanna take someone from
digital and like give them a cable show
like it never works yeah it's just wow
we're moving on we're moving on maybe I
should get YouTube TV
that's what I'm saying can watch Hot
ones all day literally are you ready for
our next story something that you turned
me on to that's made us chuckle this
morning MLB fans were not happy with
Conan Gray's Home Run Derby national
anthem Conan gray grabbed everyone's
attention with his performance of the
national anthem during Monday's Home Run
Derby I'll be it for all the wrong
reasons the 23 year old a YouTube singer
songwriter turned pop star quickly drew
the ire of baseball friend fans
everywhere one said who the hell is
Conan gray and why did he agree to do
this next cone and gray should be sent
to AAA next I don't know who the [ __ ]
Conan gray is but that was the top five
worst national anthem Renditions I've
ever heard so I saw this link and I was
like oh my God people are so dramatic
and like anytime one person tweets
something negative about a celebrity it
becomes a story right so I just wanted
to watch it to make sure it wasn't
newsworthy and once I watched it I did
you know agree that it was newsworthy
because it was really bad like off Pitch
it was really bad
um and I just want to say like it's a
really hard song to sing and not
everyone can sing it so not everyone
should and that doesn't mean you're not
a good singer because you can't sing
that like obviously not everyone's going
to sing it as good as me and this is
just another example of like
opportunities that should have been
given to me Fanny Bryce that weren't
Conan gray okay question do you think
you could for our viewers who maybe
didn't see us
give them a taste of how Conan sounded
no because I can't sing that poorly no
but you did Fergie yeah this is really
like it reminds me of Fergie but at
least with Fergie like Fergie was like
trying to do something it wasn't about
the voice mine was trying too hard no it
wasn't about her voice it was about her
take on the song right this was about
his voice honestly it kind of sounded
like me it kind of sounded like maybe
his earpiece or something like he it was
like whiny yeah it sounded like he just
couldn't find his key he was off Pitch
the whole time he was like trying to do
these riffs that didn't work and I felt
bad for him but also like this is
something that really shouldn't happen
because this weekend is um All-Star
Weekend or is it All-Star Home Run Derby
I think that's all the same thing
um it's like a really big deal deal in
baseball like you need first of all
someone with major star power and I
don't think that he was really famous
enough to do it and don't these people
have to like audition yeah
yeah I that's what I was going to say
like this seems like a big deal you know
sometimes some of the smaller games
right local talent yeah supporting but
the Home Run Derby is
like what is the Home Run Derby it's
like the All-Stars for baseball yes so
every the whole country is watching it
it's a really big deal and and that's
even if he sounded great like I don't
know who that is yeah I mean I do but I
do Baseball fans know who that is no but
also like
just because you're a popular singer
doesn't mean you can sing the national
anthem and you can be a really talented
singer and still not be able to sing it
is the hardest song to sing like it's so
big and belty and like that's why the
people who we who we always like the
YouTube videos we all go back and watch
are the greatest singers in the world
Beyonce Whitney Houston Christina
Aguilera Lady Gaga like those are the
ones we watch because those are
literally the most talented singers on
the planet right and also there's a
difference between like singing a song
badly like at uh award show or this or
that versus like singing the National
Anthem badly and like it's a disgrace to
your country yeah no it adds like
another level of humility it's not like
you were the halftime performer and you
sounded bad it's like you were supposed
to represent your country and you didn't
right like the freedoms like you know
like yeah 1776 yeah yeah so it was
really bad I go watch it because it's
like really cringy and like I did feel
bad for him because it just felt like he
couldn't get his voice like to work you
know because I have to imagine he's a
better singer than that live I've never
seen him live yeah and this maybe was
would have been a good opportunity for
him to like sing God Bless America which
is always like the easier song you know
how does that one go
God Bless America
[Music]
up you know that one that's really good
but you know what I was thinking as you
were saying that you sounded amazing but
I could like see how you get into the
stadium are you saying I was bad no no
did you not hear what I just said so you
sounded amazing no but like I could see
you going to sing God Bless America for
a stadium and knowing that you can sing
it so well as we just heard no and
joking yeah of course it's like a live
performance in front of like
what is a baseball I would say Millions
well the Stadium's thousands but and
then people watch of course the nerves
are unmatched for sure for sure and like
if it was me I'd be like all these like
straight men wanting to watch baseball
and be like who the [ __ ] is this fat
[ __ ] I would be like so in my head yeah
so yeah no I'm not saying if I was
giving the opportunity I would sound
horrible I know I can sing it close your
eyes and pretend you're on the toast
yeah I know I could sing it but like I
would definitely Buckle under the
pressure
but you're you know a pop star you're
you have to be above that yeah you know
yeah he definitely all of it got to him
I have to imagine he's a better singer
than that but I just don't know how
these players who like you know they put
their faces on the screen while the
internet while the national anthem is
being played like how they keep a
straight face
yeah it wasn't that it wasn't Fergie no
it wasn't Fergie and it was like if I
just heard I've been like oh that's not
great but now then listening it knowing
it was a flop I was like oh yeah no
that's really not good yeah if I heard
it live I would just been like um but
the good news is everyone's talking
about code and gray I did not know who
he was and now I know who he is so
really all press is good press it's true
it is true what they say
um also really quickly who is the um
celebrity who got the words wrong was
that Jessica Simpson
or Christine Aguilera uh
celebrity words
I believe it's Christina Aguilera
because I feel like
that in her book like a lot of people
have oh Demi Lovato
sorry Demi Lovato what did she say like
really bad she like repeated one line
like three times apparently Rachel
platten yes I've seen that one too got
it bad that's a good rabbit hole to go
down like celebrities who have botched
the words to the national anthem if you
just have some spare time trying to get
through the day at work you know plug in
your airpods we're the best ones are
also great one of the best ones in my
opinion are Whitney Houston at the Super
Bowl Beyonce at
Beyonce saying at the inauguration and
then people accused her of lip singing
which I believe she did so then she
delivered another performance I think at
the second inauguration and was like all
right [ __ ] you all you want to see how
it's done and then did it like acapella
and it's literally like a life-changing
moment
um who else at the
I just love when people do it so
effortlessly like there's a big song
what I'm reading a Roundup of all the
worst ones who's in there Dirks Bentley
he received no mercy online after
performing game four of the Stanley Cup
they said he sounded like the drunk guy
at the bar trying to be in tune that's
really funny also um but see the
national Christina Aguilera she doubled
back to the twilight's last gleaming
rather than moving on to Gallery so wait
also with Dierks Bentley like that's a
bad choice that he's being set up for
failure
the national anthem is like literally a
show tune like you have to Belt it it's
like not everyone can sing it so why are
you getting like a male country singer
who like
like that's not the vibe yeah
yeah okay are you ready to move on to
more singing news yes the chain smokers
are going to perform at the edge of
space everyone
one of The Chainsmokers latest hits is
high and they're going they're hoping to
live up to their lyrics the hit making
Duo have signed up to get into a
pressurized capsule Tethered to a
stratospheric balloon in a few years and
performed some 20 miles above Earth in a
few years yeah the feet would make them
the first musical artist to perform at
the edge somebody does it before said
the CEO at worldview which is a space
tourism company so he's not they're not
going with one of the billionaires like
no world view says The Chainsmokers will
be on one of the company's inaugural
flights slated for 2024 and will record
a performance from inside the capsule
giving viewers the ability to experience
music and the trip firsthand I don't
really think I would ever want to be on
someone's like a company's inaugural
flight like do it a few times safely
first and then I'll consider it yeah but
still no matter how many people go to
space how many concerts they're having
up there not interested no and it's just
like
this whole Space thing like every every
like company who's doing space wants to
be the first we have the first cancer
survivor we have the first person over
75. we have the first Jew like everyone
is like trying to like Niche get
themselves so they're gonna have the
first but they said in a few years so
like literally give Elon and Jeff Bezos
30 minutes and they'll get you know give
Elon the mic yeah like they'll literally
get someone you know Billy Joel in in a
thing and get them up there yeah it's so
dumb this whole Space thing is like
really starting to bug me it's really
silly and I'm all for space exploration
for the sake of like science but not for
the sake of recreation like it's really
[ __ ] stupid yeah each flight will
last six to 12 hours wherever it was
also part of like a new space private
SpaceX exploration firms similar to Blue
origin Virgin Galactic and SpaceX blue
origin is Jeff right virgin is Richard
yeah SpaceX is Elon yeah did you ever
watch the documentary about SpaceX no it
was so good and like that's the space
exploration like I think is really
valuable like for research and for
science there's a lot of space this
isn't space exploration sending The
Chainsmokers up there no way it's PR
it's recreational fun and I think it's a
waste of money and time but the
documentary um on Netflix about SpaceX
like making recyclable reusable Rockets
was literally like I was crying it was
amazing gorgeous and they had these uh
astronauts
up in this thing for like six months and
they filmed them before saying by their
families like it was really emotional
that's really sweet I have so much to
watch I still haven't watched the summer
I turn pretty
oh my God you're in for I'm like jealous
of you like the journey you have ahead I
know I just don't know when I'm gonna
find the time and I started a new book
and it's just like I'm a 15 you know
even though it's good
you have to watch it I don't know I'm a
little behind too even though I'm all
caught up on drag race oh and who did
you say was going to win yesterday
um I believe unless they change the
rules it's now pretty impossible for her
to win why because it's so every time
you win a challenge you get a legendary
Legend star and then by the final
challenge the Four Queens with the most
stars we'll go to the finale for the lip
sync Lala perusa
Shea only has one there's two queens
with three and like five Queens with two
so I made my prediction before they
changed the rules like that's not right
those have been the rules since the
beginning with me you didn't share that
with me you just wanted to and you gave
a recap of like who's gonna win yet you
didn't include how people win
you didn't ask enough questions so sorry
you didn't tell me that what half of the
people you didn't want to educate
yourself you didn't want to educate
yourself I trusted my teacher you should
do better
me and that's on you to do better that's
on you for sure she needs to do that's
on you for trusting me okay now we know
I mean maybe the Rue is always like
a couple episodes where he's like it's a
game within a game and just changes the
worlds because she [ __ ] feels like it
so it's entirely possible that the stars
have meant nothing like Rue is always
just making up rules like he just
decides early on like who he wants to
win and he's gonna make it happen for
that person like they feel that it's a
little frustrating but I feel it yeah I
feel it are you ready for our next story
yeah this story is crazy I need to
stretch oh my God you look like Theo
I need oh no actually I want to put
Bryce down for this story because he's
going to be like so Disturbed what is it
a new reward has been offered for the
man who allegedly shot Lady Gaga's dog
walker and then this man was released
from jail by mistake
the man who allegedly shot Lady Gaga's
dog walker is now wanted by the United
States Marshals service after he was
mistakenly released from jail the
marshals offered a five thousand dollar
reward Monday for information leading to
the arrest of James Howard Jackson who
was one of the three charged with
attempted murder and robbery after
allegedly shooting Ryan Fisher and
attempting to kidnap Gaga's Three French
Bulldogs in February 2021. the marshals
put out of Satan saying he should be
considered armed and dangerous and that
he was one of five people arrested last
year but he was released due to a
clerical error in April I can't people
are the LA sheriff for April it's July
and now they're asking for help in
apprehending him because he's still on
the loose I really hope that Lady Gaga
and I'm sure that she has but like is
providing
like round-the-clock security for her
dog walker who was shot like he's armed
and dangerous and he's literally out
for a crime he committed against her dog
walker like I hope she's or like the
Marshall service is providing security
right letting someone out on a clerical
error no like when we first reported
this story that literally somebody shot
Lady Gaga's jogwalker and tried to kid
like it was such a terrible like
upsetting story and then they got him
and the dog walker was gonna live and
like it was getting better and now a
clerical error that's unacceptable
unacceptable everyone people are not
okay in April wait are we just finding
out about this yeah that's so [ __ ]
shady and they're asking for help that's
how like they don't know their ass from
their elbow oh my God people are just
people are not okay like
I just don't really understand like why
it's so hard for everyone to just like
do their jobs at a decent rate like I'm
not even asking for excellence no just
asking for the bare minimum like don't
let violent criminals out of prison
right
like what kind of clerical error leads
to that I don't know but like and why is
there never a clerical error for like
someone who's innocent you know no it's
like only for armed and dangerous people
there's no like clerical error in
Shawshank Redemption right right like so
dumb like I can't honestly he must her
dog walker must be like so afraid and
he's probably known since April so he's
probably just like having sleepless
nights I think about this man a lot I
just really hope he's okay yeah probably
looks so traumatized because it just
never [ __ ] ends oh they caught the
guy they're in prison oh no clerical
error what
it's hard to say clerical error rural
juror clerical year would you rather
have a clerical error or be a rural
juror be a rural juror what about an
urban fervor I'd rather have Urban
forever as a royal juror and they have a
clerical error and lead a murderer to be
out on the streets
I'm actually rewatching 30 Rock again
from the beginning
um and it's really interesting how
really the world juror is the thread
that keeps the show together they talk
about in like episode three yeah because
it's Jenna's big project yeah and like
you just like know things about 30 Rock
so you don't realize how they literally
talk about them like multiple times
every season oh great low fat you know
that song it's literally an episode yes
yes it's just it's such a good show like
really premium
so is this show so is a show so I'm so
glad you brought that up let's talk
about that no are you ready for our
fifth and final story some more premium
content movie news The Hunger Games
prequel Hunger Games prequel is shooting
now and here's everything you need to
know about the Battle of songbirds and
snakes get ready to return to Pan Am
more than 10 years after the Hunger
Games hit theaters a brand new prequel
film is in the works based on Suzanne
Collins's 2019 novel The Battle Ballad
of songbirds and snakes the movie
adaptation will follow a young President
Snow who was played in the original
films by Donald Sutherland Dumbledore
no Donald tether like same Bud sure
that's the character you're talking
about right Donald Sutherland you know
he coughs and there's blood
Dumbledore like the same Vibe as
Dumbledore sure
um it's about him before he and today
here it's a photo
he literally looks like um succession
yes he does but did he take over for
Dumbledore in Harry Potter when Harry
Potter died I just feel like I have
like a memory of that let's find out
yeah Donald Sutherland Harry Potter
Harry Potter because didn't Dumbledore
the actor pass away like in the middle
of the movies
and if I needed to recap no fans were
trying to cast him oh well the fans were
right I guess that's you
never seen again
so casting for Battle of Summers and
snakes who's in it one Rachel zegler
will Stars Lucy gray Baird look over her
you are because of uh like that drama
with the Emmys or whatever yeah yeah Tom
Blythe he's in Billy the Kid he'll be
playing the young Donald Sutherland
um Euphoria star hunter Schaefer oh
who's that
um what's her character's name Jade
whatever she's just like iconic and
she's becoming like a major star okay
great Jason Schwartzman and he's playing
a distant relative of Caesar flickerman
who the [ __ ] is that
Stanley no is it Stanley by the way I as
a society we do not talk enough about
the fact that Stanley Tucci was in
Hunger Games Caesar fleckerman like one
of the best characters get you a guy who
could do like all of the above Lovely
Bones serial killer Devil Wears Prada
like gay iconic art director Hunger
Games news Telecaster yeah with the
heart of gold
whatever oh and then Spotlight like
iconic journalist yeah
so he's that'll be a great character and
um Peter Dinklage is in it as well oh I
saw that news also I can't lie like ask
me how much I care I ask I'm scared ask
not at all
um like I don't even think I saw the
final Hunger Games because Peter was
annoying the [ __ ] out of me it's like
shut the [ __ ] up Peter this is not about
you it's about Gail you definitely saw
the final one they're going through now
it's just occurring to me like Peta and
Gail like
those aren't names like I know but the
whole thing is very sci-fi right I guess
oh Katniss is not a name really either
so the girlies aren't in this like Luke
Hemsworth no we're not interested
because it's and honestly that Cassie
just announced sounds like Bleak as [ __ ]
like I just feel like it's gonna be one
of these things where everyone involved
is like we're gonna be the next Jennifer
Lawrence right Liam Hemsworth that only
happens once yeah
Liam Hemsworth like doesn't act anymore
what is that do you think he made a lot
of money from Hunger Games and it's just
chilling
no no me neither I think he like can't
get a job yeah maybe doesn't have good
representation or he just like loses all
of the parts to his brother yeah because
like when I think when I was introduced
to the Hemsworth brothers like Liam was
like it and that's because I was just
like younger yeah and the last song and
then the Miley Cyrus of it all
um and then Hunger Games he was really
targeting like a younger demographic and
then his brother just like became the
biggest movie star in the world who got
famous first
and he really came up together hand in
hand and there's a third one yeah who I
think is like trying to break into the
scene but I'm just surprised that Chris
can't do more for Liam you know yeah
like a Thor prequel literally that would
be cute actually
like what is he up to
I think he probably lives a nice life in
Australia wherever he desires a little
here a little there do you think he
misses Miley no do you think Miley
misses him no me neither I don't think
they were suited for one another but
they gave it their best shot they really
did and for the sake of the film like we
appreciate the relationship like
that was such a good movie I need to
watch that last song it's so emotional
when the waves
are flooding the shore and I can find my
way home anymore
[Music]
I look at Brew I love that song Miley
should sing that more she I mean she
should sing a lot of songs no but I feel
like recently like she's really been
leaning into like the fact that her old
music is going to be like the best she's
ever done so she's always singing The
Climb she sings like does that have
anything right like she she loves it
like she's giving into this The
Nostalgia which I think has made me love
her so much more yeah but she should
sing that yeah that song is so [ __ ]
good it's beautiful beautiful that
should be Smiley that's beautiful that
should be like a really popular wedding
song like it's really stunning if
anyone's looking for a wedding song
might we suggest honestly maybe I'll
read that book next it's a book right
Nicholas Sparks yeah the last read of
Nicholas Sparks book
me neither I don't think it's so weird
but like whenever I think of Nicholas
Sparks I think of like the drama
remember he got like a scandal he has
like a
he owns like a school yeah they were
doing nefarious things at the school I
just want to look into it quickly before
I misspeak I don't want to like slander
Nicholas Sparks but there is like it was
giving anti-Semitism right yeah yeah
that's that's like that's the word on
the street that's my core memory of
Nicholas Sparks even though he's
accomplished so much outside of the
anti-Semitism yeah he was sued by the
ex-head of school for racism homophobia
and anti-semitism
well that'll do it you know yeah
yeah still a good movie
yeah yeah
it's like rolled out it's like roll doll
are you gonna buy any roll doll books
for Roald Dahl yeah yeah like the thing
is like if we just you know like didn't
support every anti-semitic person like
there's just so many like we wouldn't be
able to leave the house and like what I
should suffer know that that's
anti-semitic that I should suck I can't
enjoy a book yeah or a movie yeah
what was that movie with Mel Gibson
yeah
you ever see it no me neither
okay so those were the past five stories
I feel as though you needed to know them
in some weird way did you know the last
one no someone else there wants to know
yeah did you ever you never thought
about reading The Hunger Games books
like no like saw the movies I remember
the plot and now I'm older okay I'm
older what's that from Beauty and the
Beast when chip is like I'm older I'll
tell you when I'm older you didn't do
the accent okay I'm older
um yeah and I feel like if I was gonna
get into like a series like that I would
do Twilight yeah but I was just gonna
say speaking of books made into movies
crawdads is in theaters now and the
reviews are overwhelmingly negative I'm
that's surprising it's a star-sided cast
it's hello sunshine it's an amazing book
and story I want to give it a chance for
myself yeah I didn't read the book so I
don't care to see the movie
um and I still need to feel like that
girl Daisy
I do yeah because you like normal people
yeah I like your normal people I like
the show I think you would like kaya
from crawdads you told me not to read
the book I don't think you have the
patience for the book but you could sit
through a movie well I have to see Elvis
I have to see Top Gun Albus and then
crawdad so
so you're probably going to see none of
them I really want to see Top Gun but at
this point I've waited so long I think I
could wait for it to be on demand yeah
also wouldn't even talk about how um at
the OneRepublic Concert they have a song
that's in
um Top Gun so they performed it and then
like the screens behind them had like
little scenes from Top Gun and they
they're so smart marketing genius they
put on the screen the viral scene of all
the men including Miles Teller naked not
naked shirtless on the beach I wish and
I could shirtless on the beach like
dancing and when I tell you when miles's
face came on like the arena like erupted
I was like it was the best moment that's
so funny that was so smart of them and
the music from Top Gun is so good yeah
all right tonight the Lady Gaga one we
need to listen to it more it's so good
it's been in my liked songs you will
only tell me recently it was from Top
Gun I had no idea I just thought Lady
Gaga put on a fire single well that's
something she would do yeah and I didn't
even know that that One Republic song
was a Top Gun song it's just been like
all over Tick Tock now I need to like
listen to the Top Gun soundtrack because
it's like really good yeah it's really
the gift that keeps on giving thing I
gotta see it and yeah and I was actually
talking to Kelly teller miles's wife on
Tick Tock comments and she said like
she's extremely disappointed in you like
for not seeing the movie
and like you're supposed to be a woman
who supports other women that's so true
and here I am not yeah okay so I'm gonna
go and see Top Gun right now yeah that
works um I'm gonna see Elvis I really
like I've I by the way have you heard
about Elvis like what are people saying
I haven't heard anything bad so I mean
because it's good but I haven't really
heard like a lot you know I guess that
must mean that's good no no you would
hear if it was bad yeah yeah yeah no
news is good news yeah and apparently
like it takes place over like a long
period of time so I love that they do
like Prosthetics and Elvis gets like
kind of overweight and and like sweaty
and like Austin like is that like I saw
like I love it there's a little clip of
him on Tick Tock and he was like huge
and like disgusting looking
I'm glad because I hate when they focus
on like a weekend and it's like I wanted
to know about Elvis the man not Elvis in
this one particular moment no literally
Jackie
my weekend with Marilyn my weekend with
Marilyn I hate movies that do that I
feel like you just watched a movie well
death on the Nile it's really like a
couple days no but that's not about like
someone that I care to know more about
but they do a lot of the Diana movies
are like that oh I watched um Spencer
Spencer which was that like Christmas
right yeah the first hour and 15 minutes
and then like the
my TV on the plane like died and I just
didn't care to finish it and it was not
good yeah but like it was a weekend a
Christmas weekend at Sandringham or
something like rendering him managering
him and it was just like honestly
Chris Stewart was pissing me off the way
she was talking
like it was really [ __ ] annoying
like it was so so like
like I know I don't know Diana
personally but she didn't [ __ ] talk
like that
[Laughter]
like it was like like the neck like she
kept shaking her I know exactly what it
is and she was doing ASMR the whole time
like speak up [ __ ] you're in a movie I
can't [ __ ] hear you
she was like might die go for a drive
what was that you want to go for what a
drive yeah you can go
you're such a good movie
I bet I had subtitles on the entire time
I was watching a movie I couldn't
[ __ ] hear I'm like is this plane
really loud or is this [ __ ] whispering
and like craning her neck to the side so
like you couldn't really hear like
that's so crazy he's like I know exactly
what you're saying yeah and like she was
like 20. see it and I think it was
Kristen Stewart's way of like method
acting but like I just don't I don't
believe it was like that in Twilight too
so it's just Kristen Stewart like
putting in a steward spin on it yeah
which we really didn't need in the Diana
movie that's so funny and she just made
like Diana like the most annoying human
being on the planet
you know
so that's my movie review
[Laughter]
Ed and Roper with Eyewitness News movie
minute
okay well that's our show that is our
show I'm hoping to see everyone in
Boston tonight 6 p.m Total Wine check
the Spritz Instagram account for all the
details
um we're back tomorrow
and there's no TV on tonight no so we'll
be back tomorrow with a great show
remember that merch launches at
shopmorningtoast.com at 10 A.M Pacific
Time 1 pm eastern time on Friday
um we'll be showing you all of the
gorgeous items throughout the week on
our Instagram and in person here on the
show so don't miss it we love you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
morning Joe where we deliver stories
that you need to know everybody on
Youtube Savage and YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasting we found so
on Spotify
and we'll see you tomorrow for hump day